institutional adoption we've been
talking about it for as long as I've
known you we've been talking about it
for as long as I've known Bitcoin let me
tell you they are finally here this is
going to be more than just dipping their
toes in institutional adoption is key
for this industry to reach the stages um
and to be in the financial system at the
level that we all want it to be that we
all think it should be but really there
is a wall of institutional money and
interest that will be a core part of of
bringing this to wide Mass adoption
across every
stack all right guys bang bang got Hy
here uh you guys are one of the Bitcoin
ETF issuers you've partnered up with Arc
and Kathy Wood uh and fast start out of
the gate how do you look at the first
two weeks or so of ETF launch inflows
gbtc selling what's going on on the
market it's really exciting thank you
for having me pump um it's going a lot
better than I think anyone in the space
uh would have re would have thought or
realized uh going into this it's uh the
inflows are very high uh especially for
a new ETF uh inflows being high on day
one or day two is one thing inflows
being this High I think we sold 60
million yesterday or so uh almost two
weeks in this is sustained excitement
and it it says something um GPT PC's
Dynamics are super interesting we should
continue to see outflows the outflows uh
people may not realize are limited so
the the market makers are only uh able
to sell a certain portion on a daily
basis which is why it's hovering around
the 500 million Mark uh per Market maker
and you'll start seeing again more
sustained pressure there but it should
stabilize at some point uh there are a
lot of others that are selling out of
gbtc for other reasons like the FTX Bank
bankruptcy estate and that's part of the
downward pressure on on bitcoin itself
but aside from all of that we've
collected over half a billion in uh in
new Bitcoin um in just a few days here
so did um a number of other issuers uh
as well and so the amount of excitement
the level the speed and especially
considering the institutional investors
are not here yet is really really
exciting and and blew out of uh blew out
of the part completely anything that I
thought um this would be now when we
let's take inflows first right I think a
lot of the investors who are putting
capital in everyone's like oh it's
institutions but to me the institutions
take a long time to kind of make
decisions uh wrap their head around this
financial advisors they may even have to
talk to their clients so do you think
that this is just retail flows or do you
think some of the institutions were kind
of ready to go and when the approval
happen then they could just go ahead and
allocate so when people say institutions
it could mean very different things um
so far this is just retail excitement
plus the kinds of Institutions that can
move very quickly so it's family offices
it's maybe hedge funds or Traders but
it's not who you think of as a long-term
Institutional Investor like a pension
fund or an insurance company or even on
the advisory side where you have
advisors that are controlling a large
amount of assets on behalf of a large
number of customers that is not here yet
this is not eligible for those guys yet
because there are there are all these
procedures that you have to go into that
includes the product being up for a
certain amount of time them picking
eligible products there's a big due
diligence process that they must do in
order to come in um but this again adds
to my excitement because what's really
happening is we see this wall of money
and we see it and we we understand how
large it must be considering that it
hasn't yet hit us and these are the
inflows uh but it will still take a few
months three to six months from now is
when you'll start seeing significant
institutional size checks and that's
when people are coming in with single
check sizes of 100 million 500 million
50 million whereas now it's excitement
it's family offices and it's a bunch of
Traders now when those institutions that
are the really large pools of capital
start to allocate are you expecting half
a percent 1% % do we think that they're
going to be like oh we're all in on
bitcoin let's go put 5% of our assets
like like how do you all kind of
anticipate this actual size that will
move into the
market so the first thing is the the
inflection point here with the US
allowing Bitcoin atfs is that every
institution now needs to have made a
decision on bitcoin you're you're no
longer able to say I can't do this I
can't think about it right now everyone
needs to make a decision and we're
having a lot of these phone calls and
discussions and meetings where they need
to figure out are we buying Bitcoin are
we not what is our Bitcoin decision then
past that is uh which and I think the
answer is clearly going to be yes but
how much in allocation uh and it it
varies it varies from family offices on
one end that could be a little bit more
aggressive to the Pension funds or the
insurance companies on the others but
some of the largest institutional
investors that we are speaking speak to
that are actively engaged that are in
active discussions that are very excited
and making plans I mean even even a 10
basis point or 20 basis point allocation
uh from them would completely shift the
market the sentiment um and I think be a
sign of more to come but probably um
nothing crazier I think the five and 10%
allocations is probably on the fund size
on the family office size uh something
started lower than that probably how do
you think about um the bull market
playing into this I I got a lot of heat
earlier this year when I wrote that the
ETF approval probably would not bring us
to an all-time high we would still need
the having plus loose monetary policy I
don't want to call Victory yet but so
far it looks like that may be true we'll
see once the selling pressure kind of uh
goes away if that is true or not um but
do you think that a lot of the interest
will come after the having and kind of
once people start to wrap their head
around you know more of like what
Bitcoin is as an ecosystem and as an
actual system than just oh now an etf's
been approve so I have to allocate to it
yeah I think I'm super comfortable with
you waving the victory flag already I I
agree with everything that um that
you've just said look most of the people
that are buying this could have bought
it in a number of other ways we're the
biggest Global issue of crypto etps
right um before this and so where
additional buys can really have an
impact on our space is when the
institutions come in and like we just
said they're not here for a few more
months so it's not that the Bitcoin ETF
is not going to Herald this new phase
and and be of incredible excitement it's
that the institutional flows through the
Bitcoin ETF will do that that is still a
ways out in the meantime I agree with
you there's a number of additional
factors here monetary policy being one
of them um the world has not healed yet
you're in the investment space I don't
think we're back I don't think VC is
back I think it's still quite fragile um
we we now see light at the end of the
tunnel but we're not so sure how far
away it is and it it could be a few
months it could be another year and I
think monetary policy will need to
change in a positive direction to give a
more positive sentiment before we start
even having a conversation about
all-time highs and a new bull market and
all of that I think we're sort of in no
man's land it's clearly not a bear
anymore but I wouldn't bet all of it um
that that this is a bull market and and
that um Off to the Races and have no
worries um The Happening is a very
important factor uh you of course know
about it it will make it uh more scarce
more difficult which if demand is higher
then leads to some interesting um price
appreciation and things like that but I
think that's early as well so let's see
what ends up happening with the
happening and let's really see what ends
up happening with the institutional
flows in a few months with a background
of sensible monetary policy and a soft
landing and um starting to reduce some
of these interest rates not just in
America but around the world and at that
point we can talk about what does the
next bull market look like and what is
feeling
when you think about um that bull market
we historically have seen about 18
months post having we've historically
seen hundreds of percent of appreciation
um but now the holder base of Bitcoin
may be changing a little bit one they
rebalance as assets increase uh two the
introduction of derivatives um you know
many different components are changing
here do you expect us to just repeat as
bull markets or do you think that
there's a change positive or negative to
what these bull markets could look like
this episode is brought to you by frck
historically the wealthy had a hidden
secret in investing they would spend a
lot of money and use very big teams to
conduct tax loss harvesting tax loss
harvesting is the timely selling of
Securities at a loss to offset the
amount of capital gains tax owed from
selling the profitable assets later but
now frck is bringing this incredible
advantage to any investor they'll
literally lower your tax bill regardless
of how much money you have they use
state-of-the-art technology through a
product called direct indexing to allow
investors to invest in the S&P 500 while
getting all the benefits of tax loss
harvesting without the big Bill if you
want to learn more go check them out at
fre.com that's
fc.com I'm a big fan of the product and
I even became an investor in the
business frk.com go check them out today
I think crypto is a very diverse place
it's not just Bitcoin even though that's
the only asset we've mentioned Bitcoin
has grown tremendously and still has
Room to Grow but clearly it is no longer
that seed stage or series a startup and
so if you if you talk about percent
gains um it should look very different
from say a nent growing area of crypto
which for what it's worth is what we
have been seeing with previous bull
markets is that we're inventing
something new we're adding something new
to the crypto space whether that is nfts
layer 2s more smart contract um
scalability uh Solana summer what
Avalanche did what BNB or polygon have
been able to do and so I do think that
Bitcoin is going to lead the charge here
and there's a lot of attention to it and
it's it's still it's still very much a
new asset but it is a more mature new
asset so previous uh percent gains for
some of the bigger assets are just not
realistic I mean if you if you think
about how much Bitcoin has gone up in
the last bull market or even crazy you
had the one before the one before it um
these are outrageous things uh to happen
in the short term and I think my we
we've talked a lot and my single biggest
pet peeve on on this whole Space is our
lack of long-term thinking um
the we do not need to see 1500% gains
for us to be excited about either the
viability or the future of this asset
class we need to see more users more
more customers so I'm comforted by um
the onchain metrics that we're seeing um
21 Co is uh the largest um uh producer
of dashboards on d.com and we display
all the wallet addresses um among other
analysis but we display wallet addresses
across a bunch of different networks and
you can see it steadily going up and to
the right more usability more wallets
more unique customers not just in
Bitcoin but elsewhere
um and if we continue to do that I'm not
really that worried about the price too
much um I'm sort of a unique crypto CEO
and you've made fun of me uh for this a
few times I don't really know what the
price of Bitcoin is on a daily basis nor
do I care I'm really in this for uh the
long term the long term and so I look at
all these other factors and I find
things that are incredibly comforting
and
exciting now we've been talking about
the Bitcoin ETF there's also a whole
long tale of other assets and uh some of
them are starting to get uh some ETFs or
ETP type coverage how do you see the
difference between like the king of the
industry in Bitcoin and kind of
dominance of market cap versus
everything else and and the interest
That Wall Street may have in those
assets so again it's different levels of
uh development stage uh we are the
world's largest issuer of crypto etps
and we have 50 or so etps around the
world um with assets uh that are small
like arbitrum optimism algorand and
Bitcoin ethereum Solana Etc um there's a
tremendous amount of Interest across the
board it takes a while though so Bitcoin
has come across the line um I can talk
to much about ethereum we have an active
filing there but we globally have have
been very excited about ethereum and
bringing the rest there are challenges
once you um incorporate things like
staking there are challenges when the
regulatory uh rules have not been fully
written there and so it may take a while
but it's also inevitable um and I think
we we we should be able to see across
the world um more acceptance so other
countries that may have only allowed us
to list say Bitcoin and ethereum are now
allowing us to list alts and so on and
so across the board I think more
regulatory Clarity um dealing with the
Bad actors as we have and as we are
continuing to do should allow us to open
up uh more availabilities for everything
across crypto not just Bitcoin um
Bitcoin is going to be very exciting at
one point if you look at specific
Industries at one point there has been a
dominant company that sometimes has a
disproportionate amount of influence or
uh market share of that company and and
so again I go back to usability as long
as we're building applications that more
people are using that are making
people's lives better
hopefully we get to a world where
Bitcoin is a small part of the crypto
climate um and the crypto landscape not
because Bitcoin has has has shrunk or
anything like that no it's growing and
growing at a really nice Pace but
because everything else is being
developed and growing as well when you
think about
regulation obviously Bitcoin green light
ethereum we'll see other assets don't
seem to be yet Up For Debate what's
changed in the United states on the
regulatory front and then is us uh
taking inspiration from maybe other
places on regulation or other places
following the US like how do you see the
relationship on the regulatory front so
uh I've been in this for a while now and
I do think the US is taking inspiration
from other places uh the amount of
things we have been able to do at 21
shares around the globe um we're still
not able to do in a lot of geographies
including America um some of the
products that we have on on the European
market um are abs are quite special and
complex and will not be allowed in
specific geographies for a while um that
said I think there's um time has passed
uh and a lot of interest has has been
maintained and so in a way this has
become way too big to
ignore it's not going to go away there's
significant interest and at this moment
it is far safer far more efficient far
more institutional
if you think about our service providers
the market makers the custodians now
we're we're dealing with a very
different caliber and a very different
class of people than even what we were
doing a few years ago um around the
globe that have entered the space um and
clearly that has an influence on the
regulatory view on
this now when you look at that geography
regulation is one piece of it but also
investor interest asset interest Etc can
change geography to geography what are
some of the things maybe that you've
seen in Europe versus the United States
that would uh surprise people we've seen
a lot more interest in for example short
or leverage depending on geography and
types of investors I think we have the
world's only short crypto etps we have a
short Bitcoin and a short ethereum very
good hedging um different strategies but
they also appeal to different
geographies um there are a lot of
geographies that want to enter this
space but need AIDS in order to do that
um I'll give you two examples very
quickly um one
is a significant amount of people that
are interested in Gold that are gold
bugs would be interested in Bitcoin and
a lot of the early bitcoiners were fans
of gold so one of the things that we've
done is we've combined the two in
various ways in specific geographies and
it's been quite successful we've
combined for example products that have
mostly gold with a little bit of Bitcoin
location or products that are mostly um
volatility reducing Bitcoin with a cap
on the upside again to ensure that more
conservative investors or more
conservative geographies feel more
comfortable going into such a volatile
asset and learning more about it that's
one example another example is our
efforts in the Middle East um where the
largest issuer crypto etps in the Middle
East as well we've listed in Dubai we're
working on a bunch of other geographies
um there are a number of for example
more conservative Islamic banks that
cannot invest in non Sharia compliant
assets so we've spent a lot of time uh
ensuring that all of our products that
are eligible to be Sharia compliant are
Sharia compliant such that these very
large places like Saudi Arabia the UAE
qar Etc um are able to buy these
products and are able to buy it in large
volumes across the board and so specific
populations sometimes times are looking
for or need or are more comfortable with
different things and is our job as a
global player to uh think about that
customer by customer and offer that to
them at the end of the day when you see
geographies maybe that don't get that
much attention South America um Africa
compared to I'd say like North America
Europe and Asia um is that just hey
they'll get there eventually obviously
we see Kelly in South America right you
know kind of really pushing stuff uh
Central America's upand cominging I
think user of some of these Technologies
we also see places like the Middle East
who now seem to be leaning in much
heavier so what what about some of the
geographies that don't get talked about
that much so I think this is um this is
super super interesting and it's a core
part of how we think about things at 21
Co um I would put I would put the non-
troubled Middle East as part of Europe
and Asia and so I actually think it's in
the same bucket like Asia on some
Financial regulations sometimes they're
they catch up
um and that's one bucket we do very very
well there but this is an area where
tokenization really plays a big role and
what I mean by that is there's a
significant interest um in some of these
geographies in crypto but
perhaps the way that they would like to
get exposure to defi assets or the way
that they are able to get exposure to
defi assets um is an index not in ETP
form but in erc20 form and that's that's
why we have built a lot of our products
in tokenized formats as well so that you
can buy access to an index or a basket
or a strategy as an erc20 token as a
Solana token or as an ETP ETF or
whatever and I think that's possibly how
a lot of these geographies may end up
participating here which I would argue
um is going to LeapFrog the whole
industry and the whole world into a
direction where actually they're using
the newest rappers tokens which will at
some point replace all the old rappers
that you and I know and work with
whether that's mutual funds ETFs funds
private funds in general um and so it's
a very interesting ground for
experimentation and it's a very fertile
ground uh that is full of excitement but
the infrastructure just may not be there
I'm Egyptian it's a big country big
economy stable lots of interest in
crypto but the financial markets the
Egyptian Stock Exchange is not something
that is heavily used people are not
buying stocks as much but the amount of
wallets in that country per capita is
probably higher than some other
places what about tokenization in terms
of like these real world assets that
seems to be a topic that's becoming more
popular you're talking here about ETFs
that could be tokenized where are we in
that potential ution and how do you see
that evolving the infrastructure is is
there to support it the issue with real
world assets has always been the same
which is what's the tradeability how do
I exchange these things um and it is
unclear right now that there is a huge
Market that is ready to buy them in this
form uh and that's that's been the
impediment historically and that hasn't
changed I think there are hybrid
approaches here so I think stable coins
are a form of tokenization it is
tokenizing the US dollar the Euro or
other currencies I think the Commodities
that we have seen gold especially uh
with some gold stable coins is
tokenization and so I think that before
we get
to real world apartment assets or real
estate assets or even sometimes
sometimes I love how complex people are
with the first examples of you know uh
can we be trading sugar Futures
prediction markets at some point but can
we just trade silver first um in a in a
scalable way and so I do think that when
we talk about real world assets things
like Commodities things like ETFs which
already have trading are far easier to
uh ramp up and put in this new tech
wrapper rather than something that even
in the traditional world is highly IL
liquid
today now in that World um there's a
governance component there's also this
idea of
um transparency auditability Etc um we
saw bitwise publish their Bitcoin wallet
address I'm guessing now that everyone
will do something similar to to some
degree what are the pros and cons of
this transparency coming because I think
everyone's like oh it's awesome that we
can go see but then we also saw somebody
send some SATs to the wallet address and
now it's like an over collateralized
thing which actually may be a bad thing
and so talk a little bit about pros and
cons and as somebody who is an issuer
you can publish the wallet address but
how are you all thinking about it
today's episode is brought to you by
espresso the maker of the world's
thinnest portable display now listen up
if you're like me you feel like you are
at a command center when you sit down at
your desk I got a gazillion tabs open
and different windows for different
activities there's my web browser my
text messages I've slack open and I got
a Notes app I normally work on a desktop
and it can be very very productive but
everything falls apart the second I
leave my desk if I'm traveling if I go
to a coffee shop to do some work or just
want to work from the kitchen table my
laptop doesn't have enough screen space
I lose my command center and my
productivity falls off a cliff it's a
major problem but this is where espresso
comes in they have a portable screen
that is so beautiful that you think
Steve Jobs came back from the dead to
create it the thing is incredibly light
it comes with a nice stand and the user
interface is so easy that I figured out
how to do it in less than 3 minutes if
you listen to this podcast you know
that's not an easy feet so the espresso
team and I we became friends I got to
know them cuz I really like the product
and those screens they now want to offer
them to any fan of the podcast so we
struck a little deal here's how it works
anyone who listens to this podcast can
go to
us.
P.O or that's too confusing just go
click the link in the description if you
go to espresso's website they've got a
brand new offer there sitting for you
you get a little discount and you'll get
a beautiful screen trust me I use mine
every day you'll love the espresso
screen and I think it'll make you more
productive go check them out today by
clicking on the link in the description
yeah yeah so um bitwise I would say is
uh is both a friend and a competitor and
and we wish them the best um I think
we're under the philosophy that a great
tide will lift all boats and and we're
not at war with each other um we
disagree with this approach um for a
variety of reasons and I and I and I can
go through it it is something that we
could have done many years ago in Europe
as well but we've chosen not to due to
some of the things that you brought up I
think transparency let me start with
this transparency is absolutely vital it
is required um the concept of an audit
Double Entry bookkeeping is so wonderful
uh and the issue that then comes um up
is well who is doing the audits um can
they be trusted is it a manual process
so anything that automates that anything
that offers additional
verification is absolutely vital there
are a number of reasons why a financial
ETF issuer should not simply share a
Bitcoin wallet
address as some people have have noticed
and mentioned and been concerned by it's
one wallet we don't have the same setup
um we have a dozens of wallets it's a
segregated wallet multiple wallet
structure that ensures clear separation
of
funds um it's cute when someone sends
SATs to uh a product and makes it over
collateralized it's a nightmare when
someone sends something that you cannot
identify that could possibly be North
Korean or Iranian that could then give
pause to advisers that as we've
mentioned on this uh on this chat
already are key to the institutional
demand and things like that and so there
is a way of doing this we will soon
published our way of doing this with
demonstrable real proven proof of
Reserves which we should be doing but
without displaying a single Bitcoin
wallet address where everything is is
located so overall I hope that crypto if
anything brings more transparency to the
markets we are actively pushing in this
direction but uh I was reading your
newsletter uh this
morning you can have companies verify
their
financials
without giving us access to their bank
accounts and that's where crypto
comes in that's where oracles come in
that's where a lot of interesting Tech
can enable that to happen and we will uh
very soon talk about how we're going to
do this uh but we absolutely want to
share with everybody exactly how much
crypto there is and have that be proven
and have that be out of our
control when you think about
um test attesting to financials audits
Etc um is the world going to kind of
coexist like what an onchain world and
an offchain world and the way that we've
done things in finance for a long time
will coexist now with this new like
onchain type verification or do you
think actually the onchain world maybe
doesn't have as much legs as people hope
it does I think the best comparison is
cash with our electronic forms of
payments and I'm guessing that we mostly
use our credit cards and bank accounts
on this call but you could go through
the world operating in cash so at some
point
um everyone will be pressured in a good
way I think to become more uh
transparent to become more onchain to be
able to do all of these things in an
automatic programmatic way it's not that
you can't do the other system and it's
not that the other system won't exist
and it won't exist for you know specific
Pockets uh of Industry specific pockets
of geography specific pockets of people
but buy and large I think the pressure
will be on this system that we all agree
is not corruptible that we all agree is
just computer code and Mathematics that
we can all verify and trust and of
course I think they will both coexist
the real question is which one will be
bigger and my my my prediction is that
crypto and everything as it gets
tokenized and therefore entered the
crypto universe is going to overtake the
world um much in the same way that most
of us are paying with electronic forms
of payments electronic Banks rather than
cash or barter even though we still do
that in some
Pockets what are you most excited about
going through kind of this bull market
what are the things that you're thinking
about or uh you're looking forward to
that maybe people aren't paying enough
attention to yet institutional adoption
institutional adoption we've been
talking about it for as long as I known
you we've been talking about it for as
long as I've known Bitcoin and let me
tell you they are finally here this is
going to be more than just dipping their
toes in institutional adoption is um is
key for this industry to reach the
stages um and to be in the financial
system at the level that we all want it
to be that we all think it should be and
that hasn't been the case for a very
very very long time um the in
institutions have been flirting with it
dipping their toes here or there um but
really there is a wall of institutional
money and interest that will be a core
part of of bringing this to wide um Mass
adoption across every stack and uh we
should we should remember that this is a
very unique Market where the retail was
the one that led uh typically in
financial history it's almost always
institutional money that leads and then
retail follows as a result I would argue
retail reaped all of the biggest rewards
but institutions given their size and
given how large this is still have a
profound effect to make and it will it
will cause this industry to grow up it
will cause this industry to have staying
power it will cause more Innovation and
more competition and for anyone that
cares about crypto like you and I that
is the single most exciting thing thing
that we could be working on this year my
last question for you is uh there's an
obsession with the number 21 21 shares
21 co uh 21 in terms of fees where does
the obsession with 21 come
from do you do you know the answer to
this it's l to bitcoin I do
not 21 million Bitcoin that's the
maximum that will ever be created well I
know that I didn't know that was where
you got the 21 from though that's where
we got the name from that was the
inspiration it was an homage to bitcoin
because it is this thing that has like
you said enabled bit uh the rest of
crypto uh to function it is the big um
gorilla in the room that is impossible
to ignore and we wanted to pay tribute
to that in some way um a couple years
ago we wanted to launch the world's
cheapest uh Bitcoin and ethereum etps
and so we ended up uh doing that in
Europe at 21 basis points and so when we
came to the us we replicated that
strategy and matched the pricing that we
already had in Europe um at 21 basis
points it's uh it's a little tongue and-
cheek with the company but we like it um
and we're big fans of uh maintaining
history and and paying our respect to
bitcoin I love it makes so much sense uh
where can we send people to find you on
the internet or find out more about 21
Co and 21 shares 21 shares.com uh 21.co
is the company side if you go to 21
shares.com from around the world it will
figure out where you are and it will
give you the products that you are
eligible to buy awesome I appreciate it
very much I've enjoyed watching you
build this business and uh I think that
you're on on the right track so we'll
definitely do this again in the future
thank you so much